foreign
so this is continuing a bit on the lines
of Albert's talk talking about click and
average case complexity this is based on
a recent joint work with Aaron potakin
and kid henris
so Albert gave already I think a great
introduction to this talk so I can skip
a few things but just uh okay we're
interested in the click problem we're
given the graph G and integer K and we
want to know whether G contains a k
click
and we know this can be solved in time n
to the K simply exhaustive search look
at all subsets of size case if any of
them are click and we're interested in
understanding if this is optimal
um just a second
okay so there are many results in
computational complexity about uh how
hard this problem is it's been studied
yeah since the early ages of NP
completeness and there have been yeah
results in
um
in particular under eth that we actually
require time into the cave where uh the
dependent should be linear and K and
exponent
um yeah and it's been been studied in in
these different models in proof
complexity however uh there's much less
to be said about uh the exact lower
bounds per click
so I will Define exactly what this quick
formula is later on but now it's just
it's a formula stating that a graph G
that's given to us has a k click okay so
what do we know in proof complexity
uh as Albert also mentioned there are
three like resolution refutations in
size and to the K because tree-like
resolution can do this exhaustive search
in terms of lower bounds well uh we know
for tree like resolution both worst case
and average case matching lower bounds
and to the k
and
uh actually to like generalize this to
other proof systems uh even like for
resolution it's an interesting problem
because it really requires new ideas it
doesn't follow directly from if you
really want to get like the type lower
bound it doesn't follow from from with
um from like random restrictions it's
the techniques we have don't give us
something there so it's an interesting
problem also to develop new techniques
improve complexity
uh and yeah a few years ago
um we had the result for regular
resolution showing average case hardness
for this system
um and in terms of
um types lower bounds that's pretty much
all we have in proof complexity
and here the average case I'm just mean
uh it's a random graph and vertices and
Sample every edge with probability p
an HSP so that there's no K click like
somewhere close to the threshold
okay I'll talk about other quick results
later on but just in terms of like uh
type results this is basically what uh
what we have
and for this talk I'll be focusing on
um Cheryl Adams which Albert called some
of monomials so here we have a set of
variables where I think of two formal
variables one for x i one for uh not XI
and I have the Boolean axioms uh
represent Clauses as polynomial
equations and I consider these Boolean
axons and the polynomial equations I get
as the axioms of of the proof system
and uh Shirley Adams derivation that a
polynomial should be non-negative I'm
simply multiply all my axioms by any
polynomial if these were if there's a
satisfying assignment that sets
everything to zero I'm going to get 0
here
um and uh and all my monomials are
always non-negative and I multiply them
by some non-negative coefficients so
this should be no negative so this
should be a proof that P is non-negative
so what uh complexity measures we're
interested in here is degree maximum
degree of of all the polynomials
appearing and the proof and the size the
number of monomials like if I expand
everything as a sum of monomials how
many monomials I get
and uh refutation to show that like the
accents are unsatisfiable would be to
derive minus one because that would be
saying that minus one is greater or
equal to zero
okay and what will actually be
considering here is the unary version of
Charlie Adams so the Restriction there
is that the coefficients have to be plus
minus one
okay and then when they count
the size I'm just looking at the number
of monomials so if I did want to have a
larger coefficient I actually have to
write out the monomial several times
this is the the proof system we'll be
considering it's unary Shelly Adams
uh here there can be minus ones yeah
yeah only here
should be like a minus and the question
it doesn't have to be because I can
always like some uh if I had like my
Nissan things here so you can still get
minus one
function you have to have the actions to
talk about the twin variables right yes
okay so yes whether you put those axioms
they're all in what actions okay yeah
right why is this uh conflict
right well it can if
we can abstract rules which are with um
with messages and then I can just write
out everything
is complete for integers
I think if you start with
uh I mean yeah
in particular it can like if you have a
tree like resolution reputation it's
very easy to see
is still in minus one
under this regime
yes
and in that case it's not minus one yeah
without this then you have to allow for
like larger larger coefficients
is just not allowing this part
and then um here I have fill out
um
can't restriction minus one but anything
negative
okay
um so these are some proof systems you
might have seen now during these last
days uh these have come up more we have
um yeah tree like resolutions and then
the students at Shirley Adams uh the sum
of monomials some of squares up there
so what do we know what we mentioned
before what do we know in terms of uh
tight lower bounds for these proof
systems here is only tree-like
resolution
so in order to like make progress here
we can also study like intermediate
um proof systems so that's what we did
we studied regular resolution
um and these are these unary versions
which I'm considering the stock which
are also intermediate and it's been
shown
yeah so this indicates simulation and R
indicates that it simulates over the
reals so new students that you can
Define over any field
and and uh Charlie Adams simulates no
students that's only over the wheels
so in that in that earlier work we
showed this hardness for regular
resolution and then this work we're
considering unitary atoms
and just to mention like it's like these
are it's been proven that these are
incomparable like resolution and new
narration yes
okay so yeah so these results are tight
and their average case lower bounds and
here just to mention some related
results so uh for resolution we do have
other results which follow from some
kind of with our arguments or but
they're not types they don't not really
like enter the case I'm not mentioning
them too much here we have uh some for a
specific encoding of Click it's easier
to prove lower bounds and then we also
have lower bounds even for Red's k
um and and they're also like degree
lower bounds for sum of squares uh in
the average case complexity but not size
for instance in terms of tight sites
that's all we have
uh so the quick formula uh we're going
to consider of the block encoding which
is somehow the encoding that if we can
prove lower bounds for this encoding
this implies lower bounds for like
natural like all natural natural
encodings
so it's like a stronger encoding to work
with so we consider that we have K
blocks and variables per block and
should be much larger than K so this is
not really up to scale
um and and we have uh two types of
classes we have causes that say that
there for every block there must be one
member of the quick and that block
uh so we're looking for a kid click with
one vertex per block
and then we have uh these non-edge
axioms so for every pair of vertices
that do not have an edge between them I
add a clause saying that they can't both
be quick members
so uh actually there's one more uh enter
the K lower bound which is uh for an
algebraic proof system uh I didn't
mention it because it's so it's actually
very restrictive we're still intact uh
if we do not allow the use of this like
negated variables and this is like a
very weak proof system you can't even
like simulate tree-like resolution like
there is exponential separations uh but
let me just like show how this is a
really simple uh lower bound and it's a
it's a nice result because it actually
so shows that for any graph G the size
lower bound is the number of cliques not
maximal clicks but just any click in the
graph so that's the number of monomials
that has to appear and the proof is it's
very syntactical it's very simple it's
basically you consider the accents
uh and here I have a one if I'm going to
synthetically derive one the one must
appear on the other side and it can only
come from from these accents because
there's no other one appearing here
for other accents so it must come from
here
uh which means that it must be
multiplied by someone and now I'm
getting a whole bunch of uh variables
with degree one
and those must cancel out somehow so now
again I analyze how they they will
cancel out and they will okay still have
to come from here
and and the idea is that the only things
I can cancel out not coming from here is
when I have an edge missing and then I
can cancel them out here
so I was in such a way deconstructing
all possible uh clicks
so it's a very like syntactical
um argument and and this was all that
was known for any algebraic or
semi-algebraic proof systems in terms of
cyclone events yeah this is
but yeah
foreign
's uh lower bounds
um we we want to Define what we call a
pseudo measure which will map
polynomials to some uh real number
and and we wanted to satisfy uh that uh
axioms they should be approximately zero
like If This Were satisfiable then there
would be an assignment that was set to
this to zero I'm just saying that okay
it has to be approximately zero which
formally means that it's going to be
bounded by some minus Delta Delta
for other monomials I want to say that
they're approximately non-negative
which uh formally means that they're
like larger than some like small minus
Delta
and then if I if I have these two
properties then uh I have a size lower
bound which is uh my measure on one
divided by Delta
so to see why this is the case if we
just apply this measure on on both sides
the largest contribution I can get from
any monomial here to getting to minus mu
of one is minus Delta
uh and also from here the largest
contribution negative contribution I can
get is minus Delta so I need at least mu
of one over Delta monomials two
business repetition
um and I I'd like just to point out that
this measure we actually have to Define
it for all polynomials and not only for
bounded degree like usually when we
prove Charlie Adam third amount we
Define a pseudo distribution but only
for things of small degree and here we
really wanted it has to hold for all all
polynomials
and this is a standard we Define this
measure on monomials and just extended
linearly to polynomials
okay so this was our our click formula
and now I'd like to yeah introduce the
object which will be working with uh
these are uh K tuples they're just K
vertices one from each block and we can
think of these as candidate K clicks so
we're trying to rule out that no K Tuple
actually forms okay quick
and I can view a monomial or like if
this were also a clause I can view it as
as what I'm calling a rectangle which is
the set of all K tuples that are ruled
out
by this monomial and what I formally
mean is that if I were to set the
variables in in the K Tuple to be my
click member so those are set to one
everything else is set to zero then my
monomial gets set to one
okay so here's an example uh if if I set
uh these vertices uh any of these
vertices like two of these to one I'm
forced to set these to zero which means
that this monomial
will evaluate to one so this is the
rectangle of all the the K tuples that
are ruled out by this monomial
or any case Apple here we'll set this to
one
uh here's another example this is
actually Axiom there's no Edge between
X1 and X5
um and and anything that contains
that sets X1 and X5 to one
um we'll set this monomial to one so
this would be the rectangle
corresponding to an axiom
so you you run over three on the capital
b i is all possible uh
components of which size
outside
the eyes the vice upside down so what's
the size of this Turtle uh
the number of vertices in the graph is K
the number of axioms is like N squared
an enzymes K squared yeah all right but
you run over all size and
sets which is into the case
yes
uh how is it a square
how is it
just beat your blog VI so if each block
is of size n and your number of vertices
is let's say m then you have to have
something exponentially in it
to choose
what this is saying is that I want one
quick member per block
example
oh yeah
and then just one last example if I
consider the monomial one then I simply
have all tuples because all tuples set
this to one so that's a complete space
and I can view these rectangles they're
just a k dimensional hypercube or it's
like Cartesian product of some uh
subsets of each block
um okay so the the pseudo measure we
Define it's actually satisfies much more
than we require it's actually like a
progress measure on uh the monomials or
so what I'm what I mean here is that we
could intuitively say like given given a
rectangle how much progress does it
represent like towards ruling out all
the k tuples
um and like here I have like two
examples and I if I were to ask which
one represents more progress oh we
intuitively it's like well this one has
to represent more progress because it's
just ruling out more tuples than this
one this one's like strictly contained
in that
so this one represents more progress I'm
ruling out more things
um but how can yeah we formally formally
Define this well uh Axiom should really
represent not much progress because
they're given to me so this is an
accident this should shouldn't be much
progress
um and if I consider this the set of all
tuples well that should be complete
progress so I just derived one
what about for a general rectangle what
should be like the right measure of
progress
so in proof complexity there sometimes
we consider this what is the minimum
number of accidents needed to derive a
rectangle and consider this as a measure
of progress that's useful like for doing
degree or with lower bounds
for size the natural measure of progress
is simply what is the smallest
derivation of the rectangle
um so we could Define this as progress
uh but we know like automating finding
small Restorations is not easy so what's
interesting here is that we actually
have like a measure which captures
precisely precisely the statement
um
so let's see yeah what is the expected
behavior of a progress measure well
Axiom should be approximately zero large
rectangles uh they the progress should
be roughly the size of the rectangle uh
because if it's large enough it should
kind of behave randomly or like as
expected not too many weird things can
happen
um what happens like if some rectangles
contain some small blocks
then it's it's not so clear
um it could be the case that well this
was these were just some accidents put
together it was really easy to derive or
it could be the case that no this was
actually like a clique it was a lot of
work to derive this
um so so when we have small blocks it's
not it's not obvious what what the
measure should do so for this we had to
Define some kind of decomposition like
analyzing small blocks vertex by vertex
this is a decomposition for like any
rectangle I can just decompose it into
uh rectangles where I want only one
vertex per small block so here I'm like
decomposing and then I can recursively
decompose until in the end
either I have a large block or I have a
block of size one
uh and this can be done so that we
actually have a partition
of my original rectangle
and uh and now I can actually analyze I
can look at these these are like single
small tuples I can see whether they're
they're a click or they're uh just
derivable just just an axiom so then I
can actually Analyze This
so let me explain this uh in a little
bit uh more detail so we're getting we
can get this family of rectangles uh
where every rectangle is either an axiom
or contained in the maxim where I think
of the measure being approximately zero
it's
uh um the other option it's like it's a
click and on small blocks and otherwise
it contains large blocks and then I
think of this as a good rectangle in
measures of good rectangles are just
approximately the size of the rectangle
um or R is just so small that it's like
negligible and then I can say the
measure is negot
uh and then so I can Define my measure
my original cue as simply the sum since
this is a partition it's simply the sum
of the measure of all the rectangles
that I got from this decomposition
so this is uh morally what I want my
measure to satisfy
um but it should also satisfy additivity
so here I'm ignoring these uh negate the
accents with the negated variables and
what these are really saying is that if
I have like two rectangles which sum up
to another rectangle I need their Muse
to be the same like the sum of them use
the equal to the view of the sum
rectangle
so I need to define the a measure that
satisfies uh these properties
so I'd like to do two quick failed
attempts so very naive ways of trying to
Define this measure
um so the first naive attempt is just
and Define the measure as being the size
of the rectangle
right
uh why doesn't this work
yep
ankles overlapped
the rectangle is overlap but that's
that's not as per se a problem like it
would be okay
um but we wanted to satisfy like these
these conditions here
it's not small on accidents like accents
are actually like a big part of the
space the rectangles are big
so this actually fails on axis
and then we have another option which is
well I mean actually what I really care
about is ruling out clicks so I cannot I
can count how many k clicks do I have in
my rectangle and that can be my measure
that's zero that's zero right so that
fails on the whole space like it's it's
just zero there are no K Clicks in the
graph
okay so these were like two uh not so
smart attempts uh but let's try to like
rewrite them
uh and to rewrite them I'm going to
consider uh these Fourier characters but
what I really cares uh I have a graph G
I have a K triple t so it's just like
some K vertices and I have I'm
concentrate just on the deuce graph on
those K vertices and I have some
potential Edge I evaluate my function uh
on on that potential Edge if the edge is
present then I get a one if it's not
present I get a minus one
okay uh and then I can Define this for a
set of edges
uh and I just take the product of all
edges in my set of so it's kind of like
counting the parity of the missing edges
uh so uh using this Fourier basis I can
I can write things as the indicator that
a tuple is a click
uh I just sum overall the subsets of
vertices that I have if it's a click I
always get one because all the edges are
present so I'm going to sum over uh two
to the cages two one so I have to divide
by this so this will be one if it's a
click and if there's some Edge missing
then this is going to be zero and you
can see that there's some like
cancellation goes on on the on the edge
that's missing so this is really like
the indicator for a one click
um and if I consider it like the empty
set here then uh the character on this
empty side is simply one and multiplying
an empty side
so now using these two definitions I can
rewrite these two attempts so this one
I'm just counting the number of okay
clicks so I can just count some overall
tuples in Q of the number of K clicks
and on this side I'm just looking at the
size of the rectangle so I can just sum
over all tuples in Q of one
so it's like a stupid exercise seems
like it but uh these are these two
attempts but it's interesting one fails
on axioms one fails on the whole Space
can we get something like in between
so now for like the successful attempts
so we have our two failed attempts and
we want something something in between
so uh let's choose some C which is uh
smaller than the largest click in the
graph so I know there are quick subsides
D in the graph
and and now there's this magical stuff
so
do something in between these two I
don't some all
um edges
only the ones that have vertex cover at
most d
so uh but vertex cover I just mean the
number of vertices that I need that will
touch all the edges in my set
okay I want to cover all the edges
okay so it's probably not clear why you
would truncate that vertex cover less
than or equal to D and I don't think
I'll be able to motivate this enough in
the last minutes
um but this actually like works it
really satisfies this progress measure I
can given the monomial tell you uh by
applying this like how hard it is to
derive this monomial
okay so
um well we can see sometimes something
over tuples it's clearly like an
additive
um
measure
and it has the the property that if I
consider the expected value of anything
that's not empty uh since there's at
least one Edge present and it's uh in
here at me and this is the center is
present with probability uh a half
I didn't say I was working on G and a
half right so now it is important that
I'm working on G and a half uh
for Simplicity yeah yeah because because
of the way I defined everything it has
yeah it should be gender half
so otherwise these have to be defined
uh so then the expected value is going
to be zero if I have at least one Edge
present
so we can show that in expectation
uh the measure satisfies everything we
need like the whole Space has measure
one because an expectation everything
except the empty character is zero so
I'm just counting the sides of the space
also like the same reason for rectangles
it will an expectation will have the
right
um the right measure
and and for actions it's a little a
little bit harder to see but it's not
that hard uh since we have we're
conditioning on some uh Edge not being
present
I can pair up these characters they will
cancel I will only be left with things
somehow in the boundary they contain at
least one Edge so an expectation
whatever I'm going to be left with will
be zero so I can show that in
expectation like everything is satisfied
so now
all of that stuff to do is to show that
this concentrates and it seems like not
so high test but this is like we're
really where like all the work goes and
like we can observe all that uh if we're
going to do a union bound uh we need to
Union bound over all rectangles they're
exponentially many rectangles this
better be like uh a very good
concentration
okay how am I on time
a little bit of okay okay so let me skip
some uh uh okay I'll go through this in
30 seconds so uh Albert mentioned that
when we prove these lower bounds we
often Define random properties
properties of random graphs that we need
to prove the lower bounds so I just
wanted to say like in this case we have
uh this similar to properties that were
shown uh used before this Rich extension
property that Albert talked about uh and
then one that we call small error sets
which is I'd say very similar to the
clicked instance that uh Albert
mentioned but it's I think a lot more
natural
um it's all it's saying is that uh
um a rectangle has Osmos tuples have
neighborhoods of expected size
except maybe for a small set so there
might be a small set I removed that set
then the
um rectangle has common neighborhoods of
expected size
so we use these two more or less
well-known properties but then we need
one more which I won't have time to to
explain but we need to at least this
very very simplified version we need uh
sums of uh characters to be bounded so I
won't have time to to get into this
uh and then yeah using these properties
we have to prove that random graphs with
high probability satisfy these
properties and then that we can get
lower bounds from these properties
okay so I won't go through this
technical slide so just the final
remarks uh so a result it actually holds
for a gap version of quick which was not
the case for a previous result for
regular resolution so here let's say we
have a click of size most to login then
even if I state that there's a click of
polynomial size it's still hard for you
know Shirley Adams
and then another
um aspect of this proof it's that it's
essentially independent of encoding
um we could add any extension variables
that depends on one block and the proof
would would still go through because
we're really only working with this
rectangular structure
and it we get a very like very nice
progress measure uh which satisfies much
more properties than we actually need
and you get a an interesting like
decomposition of rectangles that
actually allows us to capture to see
what a rectangle is really not
and just to mention like yeah open
problems of course like extending this
to other approved systems where I think
the natural ones yeah resolution Charlie
Adams and even the students that's over
finite Fields
um these are all open
uh and also getting like more
combinatorial descriptions of uh some of
the properties we have or even of the
measure
um I think this could be interesting to
generalize this further
okay thank you
[Applause]
a bit behind together but maybe one
question
so can I mention that in such a proof
the degree of monomial is always
grounded by K no no no the degree might
be much larger yeah
okay why because there are proofs of uh
with degree K but here we're not really
enough like you can use larger degree I
mean in your uh in your graph there is
no extra in the block isn't it yeah
there is or there is no there's no no
ads in the block but I could mention
very several variables in the same book
oh you don't you don't require that each
word is takes only one from them their
their multiplication is now zero
there and then you're looking for a
click that takes one vertex per block
right so if if a monomial says this this
block has two vertices it could rule out
it can say that none of like uh half of
these vertices are not part of my clique
and then they will just have to mention
half of the vertices
in a monomial yeah
yeah you have the twin variables so that
with twin variables you can make a huge
right thank you very much
I see